[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNIFER CADENCE:
Hi, I'm Jennifer.
And today I'm joined by
Leslie from Globe Telecom
to discuss how they leverage
Google Cloud's no-code platform
AppSheet to empower
citizen developers.
Leslie, thank you so
much for joining us.
LESLIE ANNE HARO: Hi, Jennifer.
Thank you for having me here.
JENNIFER CADENCE: Absolutely.
All right, so first
question for you.
Why no-code technology?
LESLIE ANNE HARO: So we
introduced no-code platform
because there are
a lot of good ideas
that never really
get into the pipeline
due to failed business case,
limited project resources,
or just by mere intimidation
of justifying that initiative.
So we see that the
no-code platform
can provide an alternative
path for a business process
automation in
delivering applications
without being subjected
to requirements,
or the constraints of the
standard development process.
So the SMEs or the end users
are able to solve their own pain
points or problems through
the no-code application.
JENNIFER CADENCE:
That's fantastic.
So what problems does
AppSheet solve for you?
LESLIE ANNE HARO: AppSheet
enables the development
of niche applications.
So these are
applications that are
used for a specific process
and groups in the organization.
Individually, they may
not provide enough value
to merit building an application
in the traditional way.
But these niche applications
are in the long tail,
and the combined value is
comparable with a value
delivered.
They are a big or in
complex applications.
So with AppSheet, we are able
to allow employees to automate
their own process without
the need of a developer
or worrying about
much of the cost.
Either they find
it time-consuming
to report on a
service vehicle usage,
or when they're on site just
doing simple data gathering.
So these are issues that our
front liners face, but never
really get resolved before.
JENNIFER CADENCE:
So front liners--
I'm definitely
borrowing that word.
But that aside, it sounds like
working with this platform
has helped address a
number of the problems
within your organization.
But how has this product
changed how you work?
LESLIE ANNE HARO:
So Jennifer, we just
introduced AppSheet in our
company around four months ago.
And the result has
been very impressive.
So we conducted a
no-code hackathon program
as our adoption strategy.
So we invited all our
employees to join.
We conducted workshops, then
we gave them eight weeks
to complete their application.
And that's on top of
their usual workload.
Now, we saw a number of
simple issues that we
didn't know still exist.
And employees with
no coding background
were able to complete and
build a working solution
with immediate results.
Now, a lot of employees
are reaching out to us
to learn more about AppSheet.
So as an example, currently
we are on budgeting season.
And the finance
guys reach out to us
to build an application
using AppSheet.
So they were able to streamline
the budgeting process
by just using this platform.
And now, when we introduce
a new process, or looking
into improving our
existing process,
it is becoming a norm
to consider AppSheet
for process automation.
JENNIFER CADENCE:
That's amazing.
So what actions have you taken
to help your organization adopt
no-code technology?
LESLIE ANNE HARO: All
right, so the success
of the no-code hackathon
made a very good impact
in showcasing our employees, the
winners, and the applications
they built using AppSheet.
We believe we were able to get
those early adopters to get
their insights and
support for our program.
From there, we also started our
own Globe AppSheet community
to keep that momentum
going after the buzz
from the hackathon.
And to increase
more traction, we
included AppSheet as a course
in our Globe University.
Our Globe University leads
the learning and development
across all our Globe
business units.
So we also include some
prerequisite courses
to understand the process
improvement and basic user
experience.
Our employees should
be able to identify
the overall benefits of
the solution or application
that they plan to build.
JENNIFER CADENCE: OK.
One last question
for you, Leslie.
Since it sounds like
you're ahead of the curve
when it comes to
no-code technology.
Why should others
consider adopting
that same type of technology?
LESLIE ANNE HARO: All right.
So the no-code platform is not
a replacement of our software
development team.
We still need to
continue to create
big and complex applications
to serve our customers.
And we still definitely need
our IT developer for these.
But there are applications in
the long tail that are often
ignored or a deprioritized.
So we believe that
the no-code platform
is the solution for those.
Combined with IT
governance, no-code platform
will help speed your
digital transformation
by enabling your employees
to become citizen developers.
Your company can
solve pain points
in your process that are never
elevated to the top management.
Not just that, the
employees will also
be motivated as we
empower them to create
their own applications.
JENNIFER CADENCE:
Well, Leslie, thank
you so much for taking the time
to join us and tell your story.
And for those interested
in learning more about how
Google Cloud's no-code
technology AppSheet can help
empower citizen developers
like you, check out the details
below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]